all right if you ever get into a car
accident it can be traumatic even if
you're not injured and nobody's injured
and the moment that it happens your
adrenaline's pumping it can be confusing
and it's hard to know exactly what to do
well eric palacios from eric palacios
and associates is the sponsor of this
segment and they share some helpful tips
welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney
eric palacios and today we're going to
tell you three things you should do if
you're involved in a car accident number
one call the police this way you can
establish who's at fault and have a
police report done so you can open a
claim with the insurance company later
number two if it's safe to do so take
pictures or videos of the cars before
you move them this way you can show the
police later how the accident took place
number three obtain the other driver's
information this includes taking a photo
of their driver's license insurance card
and registration if you do these three
things you will be protected this has
been your legal minute remember to
download my app eric palacio's legal app
and you can get more information
by
going to the website or giving eric
palacios and associates a call
702-444-7777